well tonight family and friends
remembering a woman who lost her life
trying to help a friend in need 48 year
old crystal turner was shot and killed
monday
in a neighborhood in henderson as she
and two other men tried to break up a
domestic dispute
eight news now reporter sally jaramillo
spoke to turner's daughter about exactly
what happened
sally denise brittany washington is
trying to come to terms with
losing her 48-year-old mother washington
says crystal turner had a contagious
laugh
and a heart of gold and was there for
anyone in need just like on monday
37 year old sarah clark said her 39 year
old husband
andre andrews was hurting her when he
left her house clark called friends for
help
crystal turner her son brian washington
and other
man billy brown they were there when
address returned
police said andrews got into a fight
with them shooting turner in the face
the two men tried to get the gun away
from him they too were shot
unfortunately turner passed away from
her injury brady washington says
she's still grieving since she also lost
her dad a year ago
after my brother was shot he was the
first one shot my mom went after
the shooter and you know she was shot in
the mouth
but who's to say that you know if she
didn't jump in if my brother's friend
didn't jump in that my brother would
have been the only person
you know shot
officers investigating the scene found a
black revolver in the rocks near where
andrew had been sitting he remains
hospitalized and has been booked
on one count of open murder with a
deadly weapon two counts of attempted
murder with a deadly weapon and one
count of domestic battery now turner is
from california
and leaves behind three children a
gofundme page has been set up for her
as for the man billy brown is out of the
hospital as for washington he's still
been
found at sunrise hospital right now we
are wishing him a well recovery
reporting live in henderson sally jamil
8 news now